that are replaceable okay we're done so we will have you check the volume level
level and we're okay good my name is Stephen Lawson it's September 19th
2011 and we are in a room in the Valley Library on the campus of Oregon State
University so this is the second of our interviews that is basically doing when
it's falling in his personal characteristics and there's a lot of different things
I'll ask when I want to start to say by talking about the Pauline family and the
interaction that you have with Pauline's children. Peter Pauline I believe I met
Peter probably in the late 1970s or early 1980s for the first time when he
was visiting his father or his parents in California from England. Very
interesting fellow he was in a way the black sheep of the family in terms of his
personal habits he seemed to drink quite a lot and was a smoker so I think
that that some of those habits had some health consequences for him late in
life but he was a very personable very direct person with a good sense of
humor I really enjoyed my interactions with him. In the early 1990s I received a
box addressed to me at the Linus Pauline Institute of Science and Medicine in
Palo Alto California with no return address and no letter inside but the box
held what appeared to be Linus Pauline's chemistry Nobel Prize medal and I was
very perplexed by this I didn't know why it would be sent to me who sent it
except that the postmark was Europe from Europe so I knew that it originated in
Europe but I had no understanding of who sent it or why and whether or not the
medal was authentic I called up Henry Talbe who's a Nobel Prize winner in
chemistry at Stanford who was a good friend of Linus Pauline's and you know I
compared the medals and the the medal that I had got in the mail seemed to be
authentic except for the fact that it seemed to be an alloy rather than solid gold
or gold plated whatever the actual medal is I put it aside in my office and
about a week and a half or two weeks later I received the second package from
Europe again no return address no correspondence this time there was the
Nobel Peace Prize medal inside the box so now I was really stumped and very
curious as to why these were being sent to me and who had sent them and about a
week or two after that second box had arrived I received a phone call from
Peter who was in England at the time and he asked me early on in the
conversation if I'd received anything unusual in the mail recently and I
said well yes Peter I have I received two replicas of your father's Nobel
prizes and he said oh good I'm glad you got those he very graciously had gone
to the academies and had duplicate medals struck in an alloy for family members
and for the Linus Pauline Institute of Science and Medicine which I thought was
very nice of him and I think he had that done well it was around the time of
his father's death I don't recall if it was before or after but it was right
around that era when he did that I never really had a chance to talk to Peter
about a scientific work or his work in on chemical structure we did talk
occasionally about the vitamin C in cancer work that Pauline was doing in
collaboration with you and Cameron and Scott one and Peter was very
interested in that work of course although I don't know that he actually
communicated much with you and Cameron even though they wasn't the same island
there off Europe
Linda Pauline I've known for quite a long time I think I met her either a party
at her parents house in Portola Valley or perhaps at the Linus Pauline Institute
of Science and Medicine in Memo Park she's a very nice person like I said
I've known her for a very long time and I knew her husband I think perhaps
before I met her because her husband would visit the Linus Pauline Institute
in Palo Alto occasionally to talk with his father in law Linus Pauline because
they had jointly authored papers in theoretical physics and chemistry and
Barkley was a very interesting person and I remember asking him to explain one of
the papers to me that he co-authored with Linus Pauline and he said he was
stumped by it which is a very amusing I got to know Linda a little bit better
when the Linus Pauline exhibition was being planned because we both served on
the advisory committee so we were meeting together with family members and other
people from the scientific community and Soka Gakai quite often to both plan
the Linus Pauline exhibition and at the different venues at which you can
be so I did get to know her her pretty well and I remember when we moved
files from the Linus Pauline Institute of Science and Medicine here to Oregon
State University many of the files from Pauline's office were moved to
Winnegaard Hall before they were transferred to special collections and I was
looking through some of those files for one reason or another and I came
across a letter from Richard Feynman Nobel Prize winner at Caltech to Linus
Pauline apparently in response to a letter that Pauline had sent to him earlier
because the earlier letter was referenced in the response from Feynman to
Pauline and Feynman at that time had been diagnosed with an often fatal disease
and I think Linus Pauline had written to him suggesting that high dose
vitamin C may have some value and apparently in the earlier letter that Pauline
sent to Feynman he had enclosed some reprints of papers that he and Cameron had
written on vitamin C in cancer explaining host resistance and stimulation of
immune system and so forth so Feynman had written back to Pauline thanking him
for providing all this information to him and mentioning that he was going to
share this with his physician and then I think in a separate paragraph he he
started an impair phrasing that he was been thinking about Pauline's long
career very productive career and all the major contributions that he had made
to science and humanity and he closed by saying something quite clever and
funny he said no Linus I've been thinking about all your achievements and
the wonderful things you've done for society but I think your greatest
achievement your greatest contribution has been your daughter Linda I thought
that was quite funny
not really I think when I was engaged with Carolyn Linda or Peter particularly we
were either in social settings in which there were a lot of people involved so
it wasn't easy to have a protracted conversation or they were meetings in
which we had specific strategic goals and we talked about various businesses or
relationships or so forth but I never asked any questions about family history of
any of the children actually even though I had many opportunities it just never
occurred to me to delve into their personal relationships with their parents
maybe I felt it was a little improper for me to do so
Carolyn I had known Carolyn for quite a long time he came by the Institute as did
all the children from time to time so I would see them although I didn't
communicate much with him Carolyn became more active with the Institute as his
father's illness progressed and as we were struggling with future options for
the Institute and he was also the executor I believe of his father's will and
some of the elements of that will affected the Linus Pond Institute of
Science and Medicine so one thing that I discussed with Carolyn in great
detail and we communicated about many times both Orlean and writing concern
royalties to some of Linus Pond's books because Pauling had written for
instance how to live longer and feel better as an employee of the Linus Pond
Institute of Science and Medicine and he had directed that out all royalties and
revenue from that book be given to the Linus Pond Institute and when it came
time to tie up some loose ends concerning the Linus Pond Institute of Science
and Medicine I was interested in whether that same principle would apply to
some of Pauling's other books in particular vitamin C in the common cold or
vitamin C in cancer which of course again was written as an employee of the
Linus Pond Institute of Science and Medicine so Carolyn I discussed those issues
several times and he seemed to be very amenable to reason which I thought was
great.
Linus Pond Jr. I enjoy Linus Pond Jr very much and of all the children I've worked
most closely with him and I think I probably know him best of of all the
children. I had seen him from time to time when he came to California to
participate in trustees meetings because I believe he's been on the board of
trustees of the Linus Pond Institute of Science and Medicine excuse me
probably since its inception and periodic board meetings were held over the
years and I would see him but I never really met him until the Institute was
reorganized in the early 1990s and there was a desire I think on the part of the
board and on the part of Linus Pond Jr. to spare his father from some of the
administrative responsibilities and tasks associated with running the
Institute on a day-to-day basis and let him concentrate on research which
really is what he wanted to do and since time was becoming more precious
everyone felt that that's what he should do what he wanted to do which was to
focus on science. So I talked to Linus Pond Jr. after I was asked by the board to
become executive officer and then later chief executive officer of the Linus
Pond Institute of Science and Medicine and Linus Jr. became chairman of the
board of trustees he and I worked very closely together for several years and
communicated very often about financial, personnel, management issues at the
Institute. In particular there was the possibility that the former president
director of the Institute, Emil Zuckerkondel, would start a new institute called
the Institute of Medical Molecular Sciences and that we would subtly space in
the building at 440 Page Mill Road to IMMS and that was a very complicated and
somewhat controversial and divisive issue and Linus Pond Jr. and Linus Pond had
asked me along with a couple of the people at the Linus Pond Institute of
Science and Medicine to analyze this possibility and report as to whether or
not it would work practically and if so how we would manage that that sublease
and sharing of the physical space in the building. So I worked very closely with
Linus Pond Jr. during that period and then of course in trying to stabilize the
finances in the Institute which were always teetering in those days and worked with
him closely on public relations and kind of marketing in the Institute and
later very closely on trying to identify options for the future of the
Institute because with Linus Pond's demise and the problems that confronted us
in Palo Alto it was not certain that the Linus Pond could carry on as a viable
research organization or even if that was the ideal option for the future so we
spent many hours and days analyzing and debating what the right future for
the Institute might be and eventually decided that keeping the orthomolecular
medical mission as a lasting legacy to Linus Pond's work in orthomolecular
medicine which is why the Institute was founded in the first place would be the
most appropriate future for the Institute so Linus Pond Jr. and I set about
trying to identify as I said options for relocation.
You mentioned Barclay Camber when they had their other people with other
extended family or any other college out there that you had contact with. Yes.
Barclay Cam's son, Barclay Cam Jr. I believe, I call him Barkey, is a partner at
Cooley Godworth in Palo Alto and his wife was asked to become a trustee of
the Linus Pond Institute of Science and Medicine back after the reorganization in
the early 1990s and we had quite a few onerous legal issues to deal with at
the time and Barclay being part of that law firm that we hired to provide
legal counsel and advice was very helpful to the Institute and I talked with him
many times at that time and of course I saw him socially as well. I don't
believe that I had much interaction with the other extended members of the
family. At about the time of Pauling's death before he died and after he died
there were of course many visits from extended families, Linus Pond Jr.'s
family, Linda's family and others and I met many of the grandchildren and
so forth but I can't say that I really had very meaningful conversations with
any of them. You brought something up that I hadn't thought to ask about but it
makes perfect sense to you and I guess you had a pretty
perspective on the transfer of Pond's favorites from the App Museum a lot of work at the
OB offices. Yes, it was very interesting. I've always been in favor of
transparency and access and I thought that I've always thought that access to
Pauling's papers and memorabilia should be encouraged for scholarship because
there's a lot to learn there and I think the more people look into Pauling's
career and activities the more interesting and astonishing it becomes. It's
really a multifaceted project although it didn't have some concerns initially
about when I learned that the intent of special collections which I think is a
good one was to make Pauling's papers available online. It struck me as a
really terrific project especially the scientific papers, the research and
outputs and so forth but I was concerned about the correspondence being scanned
and made available online for a couple of reasons. One, many people would write
to Pauling with asking for advice on medical issues. They had cancer, they
had various disease, they had a friend or relative or a colleague with disease
and they wanted to know how much vitamin C to take or what other therapies might
be appropriate to treat this particular disease and sometimes they would
include a donation and typically the way these donations were processed the
photocopy of the check might be made and then stapled some of the
correspondence. So I was concerned that there needed to be some judicious
oversight in the way material was scanned and made available online because
medical conditions, confidential medical and financial information related to
some of Pauling's correspondence I didn't feel should be released to the
public. So I was a little hesitant in making that material available to
Oregon State University until special collections had come up with some sort of
strategy to screen that material to protect those confidential issues of
people that had written to Pauling over the years and never suspected that
their letters or information would be publicly available on the internet.
Partly because the internet hadn't existed when they wrote and and for other
reasons. Many of Pauling's files, his manuscripts, a lot of the scientific work
his correspondence were maintained by Dorothy and Monroe at the line as Pauling
Institute of Science and Medicine. So of course those files were under our
control for many years and then I worked with you and with Cliff Mead as well
who was Director of Special Collections at that time to ensure that that this
material got transferred to special collections. Although in many cases everything
was moved in one project by a moving company from the 440 page mill road
address in Palo Alto to the campus of Oregon State University and to
simplify things almost everything in that move went to our area and went at her
hall and was stored in various rooms and then from time to time those files and
file and cabinets and materials were then transferred to special collections.
I do have some memories of that the the green board that was in his office he
seldom erased from it. Sometimes he inadvertently erased things because he
would move too closely or a guest in the office would move too closely to the
board and their their code or shirt would inadvertently erase some of the
writing on the board. I once asked Dorothy Monroe maybe out of vanity why my name
wasn't on the board because I noticed that the names of some of the
institute employees were on the board and I was curious as to why my name wasn't
and he said well that's because he knows you so well he doesn't need to have your
name on the board as a monomic device because sometimes for people that he
didn't interact with regularly to associate the name on the board with the
person when they came into his office was very useful to him and the entrance to
his office was adjacent to that green board so it could very easily look from the
person to the board and back and and attach the name to the to the person that
was standing in front of him if he was unclear as to who that person might be I
think Cliff need the former director of special collections manage the
technical aspects of moving the chalk board I know that there were issues about
electrostatic disilligment of the chalk particles from the board if different
types of acrylic were used and there was discussion about spraying the board
with some sort of sealant that would forever fix the the chalk to the board but
whatever technique was used I believe a box was built around the board and
moved very carefully they didn't have standing job because as far as I can tell
there was no loss of information and when the board was moved from
Pong's office to special collections something else getting away from
calling a little bit here but something else the reference that I asked about is
the traveling exhibit to New York with Linda on the SGI exhibit yeah well I think
that the origin for that exhibit probably goes back to I know Diasaka Akeda
the head of SGI and Linus Pong had met in conversed prior to the to the
establishment of the Linus Pong exhibition so they were acquaintances and I think
SGI or Akeda had expressed a desire to do something for Linus Pong or the
Linus Pong Institute of Science and Medicine and I think although I'm not
exactly clear on this my recollection I hadn't thought about this in a while
and I haven't consulted any files but I think that the I think that desire was
transformed into the exhibition partly due to conversations perhaps with
Linus Pong junior in the early 1990s and then of course we thought it would be
a way of educating the public about this extraordinary man and introducing
school children to Linus Pong as a role model perhaps because Linus Pong
worked in chemistry and chemistry is not that sexy as subject to many
citizens in the United States cosmology theoretical physics things like that
things that Einstein was involved in or Carl Sagan was involved and seemed to
resonate with people but chemistry is a little bit difficult a little bit
oblique to many people so we thought that having an exhibition devoted to
Linus Pong and all facets of his career as a humanitarian as an activist as
a scientist as a medical researcher would be a way of honoring Linus Pong his
legacy and also introducing his incredible work to school children and
people around the world it was hugely successful millions of people saw it
in locations in Europe and Japan and many locations in the United States was
terrifically well executed and designed very very diligent and creative
design people working with Soka Gakai transform the exhibit or design the
exhibit to fit into the available spaces in DC and San Francisco and Boston and
everyone who who saw the exhibit really thought it was very very impressive
and actually Soka Gakai when the exhibit had finished touring gave all the
elements of the Linus Pong exhibition to Oregon State University I did I
went down to dear flat ranch they had a little guesthouse that was built I think
at the south end of the beach adjacent to the main house and I went down fairly
late in Pauling's life I think it must have been around 1993 perhaps even
1994 when I went there and my visit was associated with a deposition that our
attorneys were doing of Linus Pong related to litigation with health now in
T.S. Rat and I remember driving down and taking him the Sunday paper because I
know that he always liked to read the Sunday San Francisco Chronicle on the
funny so I took him that large paper and visited him at dear flat ranch and got
to see the house and wandered around the beach and it was very very enjoyable it
was a little sad too because it was difficult to see him somewhat incapacitated
but it was really a terrific experience to be there so I'm trying to get a
sense of the space here is a very important place to find and it was easy to see
why it was so important to him because it was very remote and secluded there
were no distractions a terrific natural environment in a house perched on a
bluff overlooking the ocean very tranquil space and I think it's easy to see
how we got a lot done there without any internet connection or fax might
believe it might have installed a fax machine later on but I was an ideal
place for him to work and think without distractions because when he was in
Palo Alto he was a very famous man and his time was sought by many people for many
different reasons old friends colleagues the public media and I think it was
difficult for him to concentrate at his office at the line is playing us to
science and medicine at least on page mill road because there were so many
demands on his time when he retreated to dear flat ranch he removed himself
from that contact that connection so he was I think he really loved that time
alone down there I believe the property is still owned by the family but I'm
not exactly sure what they intend to do with it
well I know that he'd like to watch some some programs on TV some serialized
programs he read quite a lot he'd love to read mystery books and I think we
may have talked about that in earlier conversation I would loan him mystery
books and he would loan me books and actually a lot of his books before he died
ended up at a bookstore in California Avenue in Palo Alto because he would stop
in that bookstore and trade books it was a bookstore where you could trade or sell
your use books for books that they had in stock so I remember looking through
the bookstore and finding Linus Pong's name and many of the books in the mystery
and science fiction area that he had brought in to trade for other books
he was interested in reading he didn't seem to have much interest in cinema in
plays in show business arts fine art music I didn't seem to be anything that came
up very often in conversation so he did not really seek out those kinds of
experiences I think he was happiest just doing his own work thinking about
scientific problems the few times that I had cocktails with him in his apartment
at Stanford he was happy to sit and talk about a wide range of things and he
liked to drink vodka and we would typically have vodka and tonic sometimes he
would just drink straight up vodka or maybe with water and talk about a wide
range of subjects but popular culture the arts were really not I don't think of
great interest in him so he was a rare individual in that there was really no
division between in my mind what he did recreationally and what he did
professionally I mean he was a scientist through and through and derived
pleasure from working on scientific problems and that pleasure I don't think
was to be substituted for pleasure in other activities I'm sure that he did a
lot of things on his own or with his wife traveling and so forth and visiting
different places with his wife that were enjoyable to him but when I knew
him best late in life after his wife had died it didn't seem that that he was
that engaged in activities other than than science
okay okay oh he was very industrious very industrious he worked all the
time as a matter of fact I remember going to parties at his house in Portola
Valley and using the restroom the bathroom and oftentimes if you go into
someone's bathroom you'll find a prevention magazine a reader's
digest or entertainment weekly or time or the newspaper or something and
Pauling's bathroom was stack of journals scientific journals
well I think it goes without saying that he was extraordinarily creative and had
an interesting way of visualizing and thinking about scientific problems and
issues so I think in terms of creativity I can't think that at least in the
scientific realm that he's surpassed by by anyone really when you think about
the nature of his stunning contributions to molecular medicine molecular biology
chemical bond I don't think it gets much more creative than that is memory was
prodigious it's rare that you encounter someone who has such a clear memory of
so many details and Pauling was very frequently able to recite the
co-authors of papers that have been published not just his own papers but
other papers that have been published 30 40 years earlier the date and the
journal and basically could give you an abstract of that particular
paper so he had an incredible memory and I think that is one of the reasons he
was able to make so much progress in science he was able to conjure facts from
deep in his memory about perhaps unrelated topics and fit them together in a
real synergistic way and and make new discoveries but I have felt my father
also had a stunning memory I won't say it was photographic but it was close to
being photographed he was able late in life to remember things that he had
learned as an undergraduate at Massachusetts Institute of Technology that I
found very surprising I would try to stump him with calculus problems when he
was a businessman and he was not stop not stumpable and Pauling was very
similar perhaps even better than my father in the on the memory score well I
think Linus playing at a healthy ego I think he was well aware of his
abilities some people I think misinterpret that confidence in his own
abilities as arrogance and I never really interpreted that way it seemed to me
that he knew what he was talking about he was able to justify his opinion or
his statements about various issues which he was talking and I think he had a
very healthy ego I'm not sure that I ever saw him angry I saw him when he was
less than happy but I'm not sure that that would qualify as angry I've seen him
concerned and maybe sad but not really angry although I'm sure for instance
during the Mayo Clinic in Brolio in the late 1970s and mid 1980s he had every
right to be very angry and perhaps he expressed his anger to some of the
participants in that controversy but I never saw him angry he tended to move
somewhat slowly sometimes that was because he was carrying a heavy box with
him with correspondence and books and papers so he never really seemed to be
fatigued he wasn't physically vigorous at the time I knew him at the
Linus playing a suicide medicine but he certainly didn't seem fatigued but he
was not a physically dynamic person how did he handle disappointment I know there
were a lot of great applications between them one day and this time he was in the
front of the advocacy and yeah I think he was disappointed clearly and all the
emotions that go along would be disappointed but he never felt dejected
because I think he felt that that he knew better than many of the people who
were denying him the grant funds and knew what was required to participate in the
grant funding game and was playing it and he was disappointed that he wasn't
rewarded by playing the game appropriately and the way he'd been told to play
it by the funding agencies so he was somewhat chagrin that he couldn't get
the money from federal agencies to do the kind of research that he felt was
very important I didn't see him angry at particular people but he was
unhappy that he couldn't get financial support to do work that he felt would
be very important in public health for instance the vitamin C in cancer work
is a case in point when Cameron had started treating terminal cancer patients
hospitalized waiting to die with high dose intravenous and oral vitamin C and
reported to Pauline that some of these people were having very dramatic
responses Pauline and Cameron collected a lot of the data pathology,
histology, x-rays, so forth and Pauline felt that that data was probably
persuasive enough to get the National Cancer Institute to set up a
randomized placebo-controlled double-blind clinical trial to test the
efficacy of vitamin C in cancer learn more about it and the reception he got
by the NCI was very negative and they always found a reason that maybe vitamin
C wasn't responsible for this response maybe it was coincident with
something else and Pauline said well that's exactly why I want these
clinical trials to be carried out to find out whether this has value and
it totally we have evidence that has value now we need to find out whether whether
it does truly have value and NCI had sort of an odd perspective on the problem
they wanted Pauline to apply for funds to study this in cell cultures and
animals animal models like mice or rats so Cameron already had some clinical
evidence but they wanted to turn the wheelbarrow upside down and start with
cell cultures and animals so typically the trajectory the normal scientific
trajectory would be to establish biological plausibility and see effects in
cell culture models and then move on into animal models to find out if you can
replicate the in vitro results in an in vivo model and then if that's all
promising then you move eventually into a clinical translation of this
of this modality and Pauline and Cameron were actually starting at the end of
that tripartate paradigm and he wasn't anxious to go back and start with
cell cultures and animals so it was I think excuse me a bit frustrating to him
and to one to you and Cameron that they were being forced to to start at the
beginning when they already had results in people that seemed to be very
promising and they believe would be sufficient to set up a randomized clinical
trial to test this in people. Were you at all privy to or involved or
observed to Robert Perrydowke's collaboration with Pauline? Well Robert
Perrydowke of course visited the institute many times because he was
Pauline's official biographer so he came to talk with Pauline, talk with
Dorothy Monroe, talk with people, call it Pauline's colleagues at the
institute and elsewhere many many times over the years and I got to know him
reasonably well. I never had much input there. I believe I may have spoken to
him in the 1990s about some of the litigation and Robinson and Rath issues.
I really don't know the status of the biography. I have no idea. I wish
a grin to learn at one point that he had no book contract and it seems to me
that if you have a book contract and that implies a deadline and you've got
to you've got to have a product by a certain date that the publisher is
interested in producing and I was surprised to find that apparently Robert
Perrydowke never had a book contract and was doing this presumably in hopes of
shopping and around to different publishers at some later date but I think a
book contract would have really been a terrific catalyst to getting that project
completed. Tom Hager I talked with him and I like his book very much actually. I
think it's probably the best biography of Linus Pauline and Tom of course had
some access to Pauline late in his career and visited the institute several
times and I was interested in I thought that the the last chapter in the end of
the book to coincide with the end of Pauline's life was perhaps a little bit
abrupt and it was interested in working with Tom to develop that a little bit
more thoroughly especially with respect to the Rath litigation but I think the
publisher was interested in getting the book on the shelves. Excuse me not
long after Linus Pauline's death in August of 1994 and I think the book
appeared in the fall of 1994 so I think that they were interested in wrapping it
up and getting it out there to sell while Pauline was still in recent
memory in the news because that would have been a good marketing opportunity for
them and I have since talked with Tom although I don't know if he has any desire
to do this or as publisher as any desire to do this in perhaps a new
edition of this book which would wrap up some of the loose ends that that
were left angling in the original book. No I didn't know that. Not very interesting.
No I never had any contact as far as I can remember with Seraphini or the
Gertzels. I read their books. I thought they were interesting. I mean I think
no book is perfect and all have some failures or defects and I think those
two books have their share of failures and defects but well I think
Pauline as a result of his campaign to end atmospheric testing on nuclear
weapons and his political activities in the 1950s learn pretty well how to
use the media and I was struck by his facility with the media. I mean he gave
hundreds or thousands of interviews to journalists and media representatives
throughout his life and he knew what the audience was and he knew what part of
the story to give to the particular interviewer for that particular audience
and he was extremely good at describing pretty complex scientific phenomena in
ways that perhaps the average intelligent person can understand and grasp
them. So he was a terrific speaker and was able to distill pretty complicated
ideas down to easily digestible communications.
Yeah that's interesting. Well of course during the male clinic in
Brolio there was quite a lot of communication between the public and the
institute and Linus Pauling because at that time although Cameron Pauling pointed
out that Craig and Mortel who organized and carried out that male clinic
those male clinic studies two of which were published had not really read Cameron
or Pauling's papers and were not prepared to reproduce Cameron's work
technically. So they never gave any vitamin C intravenous land there were other
problems with male clinic studies that have been dealt with at length by
other people. So when people heard that the famous male clinic had
apparently objectively evaluated high dose vitamin C in cancer and came up
with negative findings there was kind of a flood of questions about this
and Pauling and Cameron had prepared criticisms of the male clinic studies and
those were provided to people who were interested. I think that the only I can't
remember exactly big windfalls financial windfalls to the institute from the
direct male program as a result of public statements by Linus Pauling or
other people at the Linus Plains Institute of Science and Medicine but I do
remember that there were negative consequences from both the male clinic
studies and somewhat later when people discovered that the institute was doing
work on HIV not AIDS but HIV infection cell culture work and the effect of
vitamin C in inhibiting replication of the virus responsible for AIDS there were
people that had moral problems with that work for whatever reason and some
donations dropped off as a result of that.
What do you hear a sense of Pauling's attitude towards the money especially in this
middle of life? Well, you can assume that he was a pretty wealthy guy by the later use of his money.
Yeah I don't think money was an issue for him at least during the time I knew him on the latter
or third of his life. I feel fairly confident in saying that he didn't have any
personal money problems. He loaned money to the institute many times, directed
royalties from books to come to the institute so if he had needed money
personally I don't think he would have done that for instance. So to me he seemed
like a very generous person financially he was he was giving money to the
institute he was trying to find money for the institute to carry out research that
he felt was important. So he seemed to be very generous and altruistic. He never
seemed to be interested in doing anything that would raise money for him for
instance the patents that he was involved in acquiring weight in life, one in
superconductivity and then patents related to lipo protein A and vitamin C. I
think the goal there was not to enrich himself but to find more revenue streams
for the institute so that it could do research that he felt was important. So I
would say that's very philanthropic attitude, very altruistic.
Did you have a travel inform? Let's see. No I guess I didn't. I traveled with him
to city hall in Palo Alto from his apartment and I would often chauffeur him
from his apartment at Stanford campus to the Linus Poly Institute and take him
home in the evening mainly because although his driver's license was still
valid he had decided not to drive so much anymore and it gave me an
opportunity to talk with him about scientific issues and administrative issues
and he could regale me with stories from his past in kind of a distraction free
environment namely in the car while I was driving so but that's the extent of
my travel with him, local travel. Well in the early 90s he developed the illness
it would eventually take a while to try to treat that with an experimental treatment.
Well when he went public with a diagnosis of prostate cancer of course many
people were shocked especially as critics they weren't shocked I think they
were well I don't want to be too critical of them but many people said we've
been advocating vitamin C for all these years and taking vitamin C for all
these years and now you've got cancer how do you explain that and probably had a
very rational non-defensive response which was most elderly men develop
hyperplastic or hyperplasia in their prostate most elderly men at autopsy are
found to have cancerous cells in their prostate and it's just not uncommon it
happens to many many elderly men and he said it's quite likely although not
provable and I'm paraphrasing that his high intake of vitamin C delayed the
inevitable by 20 years and more because he died at the age of 93 and a half and
of course many men start to develop prostate problems 20 years earlier than
that so it's not a provable assertion but I think it's just as reasonable as
any other assertion about the relationship of vitamin C to his cancer he
treated himself both with high dose vitamin C although I believe he did not
take intravenous vitamin C perhaps just oral vitamin C which is a little
surprising but on the other hand the pharmacokinetics of vitamin C
had not been really clearly worked out and this was before the vitamin C
transporters had been discovered so no one really knew exactly how vitamin C
got from the gastrointestinal tract into the bloodstream and to cells and
tissues it's clear that not all of it got into the bloodstream from a large
ingested dose some was excreted some that got absorbed was excreted and some
just passed through the intestinal tract so the pharmacokinetics were not
well understood and it wasn't until after pouring died that that people started
to to look into that more carefully and we now know for instance that there are
active transport molecules on cells in the intestine that limit the amount of
vitamin C that gets taken up by cells and move from the intestine into the blood
stream so when you take large oral doses you cannot get the same blood
concentration of vitamin C that you can get when you get it intravenously
because then you bypass these transporters on cells and get the vitamin C
directly into the bloodstream and some work actually a lot of work
suggests that one of the major anti-cancer mechanisms of high dose vitamin C is
the generation of hydrogen peroxide as a result of either auto-oxidation of
vitamin C or reactions of vitamin C with metals and this seems to be selective
to tumor cells and hydrogen peroxide diffuses into the tumor cells and
disrupts their cellular machinery by different mechanisms that wasn't
really well known when Pauline was self-medicating with vitamin C for his
prostate cancer so he didn't prefer intravenous vitamin C at that point because
it wasn't any perhaps clear rationale for it. I know that he had surgery he
underwent a bilateral orkiectomy and also was taken flutamide which is a
standard chemotherapy drug for prostate cancer and I know that he was also
working with friends and colleagues at Stanford Medical School to raise
monoclonal antibodies against his prostate cancer cells and I don't really
know how those things work sequentially or whether he was combining some of
those modalities I'm not clear about that but I know that all those avenues were
were tried by him and he was actually quite public about his treatment and
about his illness. I believe the last time I saw him was when he was
deposed by our lawyers in 1994 I think it was early summer late spring or
summer of 1994 at his home in Deer Flat Ranch.
Well it's tough to have clear memories such an emotional event.
Linus Pauline was an unusual public figure in that many people who didn't even
know him felt very strongly about him either positively or in some cases
negatively perhaps and people who knew him really tended to love him because
he was such a charming magnanimous and wonderful person to be around and when
he died I think everybody that knew him was grief-stricken myself included and it
was very difficult I was asked to speak at that funeral as was the president of
Stanford University Gehrhard Kasper and a number of other people and it was very
difficult to maintain composure and talk about Linus Pauline at that event.
What was the fallout of the death sentence? Well the immediate fallout was
probably a rise in memorial contributions in honor of Linus Pauline. We were of
course very concerned about the long-term success of the Linus Pauline
Institute because many people who had contributed money believed rightly so in
many cases that Linus Pauline was at the helm of the ship and he was directing
the research and he was director of research at the end of his life and we were
concerned that absent Linus Pauline people might start to lose interest in
the Linus Pauline Institute and stop supporting it financially and we had no
endowment at the time and we had some zoning problems with the building in
Palo Alto we weren't in a least building on a commercially-zoned site
440 page mail road which was scheduled to change to residential zoning so we
knew we had to move and absent Linus Pauline no endowment and moving was quite
a challenge for the Institute and I alluded to this earlier the Board of
Trustees Linus Pauline Jr. myself really grappled for a long time with these
these issues thinking about different opportunities and options for
relocation and ultimately decided to come to an academic institution because
academic institutions except for a few tend to be permanent and we started to
look at academic institutions that were doing work that was compatible with
Linus Pauline Institute of Science and Medicine's mission where this work in
orthomolecular medicine would find a good home and be able to be carried out as a
working tribute to Linus Pauline's ideas in orthomolecular medicine.
Very lucky for us during those deliberations we were the happy recipients of a
number of large bequest and those bequest allowed us to establish at least a
small endowment I shouldn't say endowment but to have enough money to fund an
endowment for the director's chair here at the Linus Pauline Institute at
Oregon State University which at that time was matched by the state so it was
a functional $3 million endowment which allowed us to attract very high
caliber director and subsequently with the help of the research office at
Oregon State University we were able to attract high caliber faculty as well
so well that's the end of my set of questions on point I guess I'll just ask you
if there's anything else about falling to personality or personal characteristics
or the relationship that you share that you're interested in anything that is needed.
Well I think I've said before I found them to be very funny he was he was very
charming very witty of course seemed to know everyone know everything he was just
a joy to be around and maybe I mentioned in our last interview that when
Zella Kerman and I had finally succeeded in producing some material in a
superconductivity project that we all thought would exhibit a higher super
conductive temperature to see the expression of delight on Pauline's face when
we showed him the material that we produce was extremely memorable I have
vivid memories of that because he was just as gleeful as a teenager on a
first date to show him that material and he just had a real joy for scientific
discovery and I think that was the the thing that most motivated him in life.